house Speaker Kevin McCarthy can't seem
to catch a break
15 rounds of voting before McCarthy was
able to take control of the gavel
political battle over raising the debt
ceiling chaos in Congress as the
government lurches towards a possible
shutdown McCarthy has a razor-thin
majority in the gop-led house and is
facing a looming partial government
shutdown that could cost him the gavel
many Republicans think he's doing the
best that anyone could do but you have a
number of a very hard line Republicans
who either want him out or want him to
do exactly what they say and it can be
really hard to satisfy both of those
wings with such a small majority here's
a look at the power struggle amongst
House Republicans that is affecting
McCarthy's control over his own party
and how that could lead to a government
shutdown
yeah
house lawmakers are scrambling to pass a
short-term spending bill by September
30th the end of the fiscal year to avoid
a partial government shutdown the only
problem the majority of House
Republicans can't seem to agree on what
goes in that bill a faction of
Republicans is threatening not to pass
legislation if McCarthy doesn't include
their demands in any funding deal
it's a group of Republicans who are
willing to basically undercut the
party's legislation to make a point and
try to hold out for a better deal this
group of lawmakers all agree on the need
to do one thing cut government spending
but some in the group are also making
other disparate demands like ending Aid
to Ukraine and tightening border
security
some are also threatening to oust
McCarthy if he doesn't meet their
demands members of the freedom caucus
are very you know hard-line members who
want to sharply cut government spending
but then there's other folks like Matt
Gates who's not a member of the freedom
caucus but is a very very outspoken
critic of McCarthy he's got a whole list
of Demands and things he wants McCarthy
to do but at the end of the day he
really just doesn't want McCarthy as
Speaker the path forward for the House
of Representatives is to
bring you into immediate total
compliance
or remove you pursuant to a motion to
vacate the chair
this isn't the first time McCarthy has
gone head to head with Gates and other
Hardline House Republicans a speaker has
not been elected a speaker has not been
elected a speaker has not been elected
back in January McCarthy struggled to
obtain the majority of votes needed to
become speaker and during 15 rounds of
voting before he won the seat
Gates and several other Republicans LED
that opposition and to win them over
McCarthy made several concessions like
promising deep spending cuts the problem
is that every time he gets one thing
done he makes promises to some members
about doing future things to help them
out or to win them over and at some
point all those promises start to come
due
McCarthy's plight is an unfamiliar
territory John Boehner Speaker John
Boehner resigned in 2015 after being
squeezed by clashing factions within his
own party over spending cuts needed to
avoid a government shutdown Republican
house speakers have a long history of
having a lot of dissidents who nipped
their heels for years and years and try
to push them on issues including you
know deficits debts and spending what is
new is that his majority is so small
that he cannot just ignore people he has
to actually deal with them in order to
get legislation passed past speakers
could probably ignore 10 or 15 or 20
members and still get bills over the
Finish Line McCarthy cannot
to pass the short-term spending Bill
McCarthy can't afford to lose more than
four votes without help from Democrats
McCarthy's you know is a very personable
leader he likes having relationships
he's not so much a policy guy so it
really is a matter of managing his
caucus getting a bill they can pass the
republican-controlled house and the
democrat-controlled Senate will also
have to negotiate a full-year spending
agreement you know I'm not a fan of
government shutdowns I've seen a few of
them over the years
they never have produced a policy change
and they've always been a loser for
Republicans shut down or not the slim
majority and political infighting in the
house aren't going to go away from
McCarthy they're still a limiting
question of if not McCarthy then who his
number two Steve scalise is undergoing
Cancer Treatments there's other
Republicans who could theoretically
leave the caucus but it's not clear that
any of them would be in a better
position to do it for McCarthy it's just
another example of where he's in this
crazy situation and looking for a
houdini-like trick to to wiggle his way
out and it's just not clear how he's
going to do that
[Music]
thank you